[Música]
quiero elemento alarde revista de prensa
y ya está comido en el estudio Rosa
Pérez Mateu Rosa bienvenida feliz
viernes ya nuestro último programa por
este año rosa se comería un filete de
con pan de oro de 1912 $ pues no sé no
sé qué haría con este dinero antes que
transformarlo en filete Raúl yo también
hay otra cosa en vez de bueno primero
que no como carne entonces y segundos si
comiera pues yo que hacer otra cosa pero
vamos empezar haciendo referencia a un
tema que tú trabajas un par de días y es
los lectores de la revista Time y que
eligieron en una encuesta al presidente
de Brasilia ir bolsonaro como la persona
más deprimente del año rosa pero como
fuese campaña silenciosa que coloco a
bolsonaro en la revista Time
y la salud en el medio o globo y explica
que esta fue una campaña orquestada
tanto por el círculo como por los
seguidores del presidente de Brasil a
través de 100 canales de telegram y 85
grupos de WhatsApp en las que se daban
instrucciones no solo de votar al
presidente estadounidense para alzarlo a
la primer puesto de esta encuesta sino
también votar en contra del resto de
candidatos así es Rosso y también
recordemos ya como comentamos está una
selección distinta de la Persona del Año
que hacen los propios editores el medio
estadounidense el resultado se conocerá
el lunes es 13 y siempre pero no miento
ya tenemos a deportistas y artistas del
año rosa
estamos hablando de Larry Nassar no sé
si recuerdas todo este caso Raúl creo
que es Harry Harry bueno si tienes toda
la razón Rosa perdóname
la la Corte Superior de Justicia del
Reino Unido ha permitido la extradición
del fundador de WikiLeaks a EEUU a pesar
de que el equipo legal de Julian Assange
se podrá recurrir este caso la decisión
de hoy ha llenado titulares aquí
solamente hemos seleccionado un par de
ellos pero recordemos este caso se ha
seguido por los medios de comunicación
alrededor del mundo porque ilustra muy
bien este debate entre el derecho a la
información y la protección de secretos
de Estado porque recordemos que Julian
Assange
sobre el pez Ana cargos en Estados
Unidos sobre todo por delitos de
espionaje por haber revelado crímenes de
guerra en las guerras de Afganistán
Idaira rosa y cerramos con Google porque
ya es una vía principal que usamos para
poder conocer el mundo y encontrar
respuestas a algunas preguntas que nos
hacemos y ya hizo su resumen de lo más
buscado del año
resumen encontramos preguntas que todos
nos hemos hecho sobre cómo sanar cómo
salir de esta crisis también como
levantar nuestra salud mental nuestro
estado de ánimo cómo honrar a las
personas también muchas búsquedas
relacionadas con la lucha por la
justicia racial no con la lucha
antirracista también momentos humano sea
de esto Raúl con los que todos
empatizamos no reencuentro sé después de
estos largos encierros de estos largos
confinamientos dónde puedo recibir la
vacuna contra el covid cuándo puedo
visitar a mi familia paragolpes
preguntas que ya se han convertido en
universal Rosa muchísimas gracias
entonces por esta última
revista del año
que llevamos